term time is delayed for many school
children across england with the
education secretary telling us this
morning
that he is hopeful those primary schools
that do not have a return date at the
moment
will reopen i'm joined now by paul
whiteman general secretary of the
national association
of head teachers and paul thank you for
joining us in this morning
um when i was speaking to the education
secretary he
suggested that a week was enough time to
have a uh
set up a fully functioning testing
system and do you agree with him
that's not what the members that i
represent are telling me
um putting a testing center together
that requires seven distinct roles
uh for staff to undertake we're told
through the government's guidance
that it will take nine staff some three
hours to test 100 pupils
this is a huge undertaking and it's a
huge undertaking that directs attention
away from the education effort and what
we've been saying to government for some
time now
is if if education really is the
priority that you say it is
stop laying um duty upon duty upon duty
on schools let them get on with the
education effort and bring support in
uh to undertake these tasks we we accept
that mass testing could be a game
changer for schools
but we can't administer mass testing and
educate at the same time so we really
need some support
with all of that in mind and given the
fact that um so much of the country is
now
seeing tier four restrictions do you
think schools should reopen
not until we're ready to do so so we
were we were talking to government
uh about three weeks before the
christmas break three weeks before the
end of term
looking at the data looking at the
indications particularly around
secondary schools and saying then
make the decision now that there'll be a
later opening so that we can plan
during those weeks to have an orderly
return to school properly supported
and yet again the government makes the
decision at the very last minute when
there's no time to plan
and no time to react to that decision
and the decision that schools and local
authorities were trying to take on their
own accounts shortly before
uh christmas uh and then the government
threatened them with legal action for
trying to organize
uh a a an orderly uh orderly arrangement
for education
this polarized debate about school gates
are open and therefore education is
happening or school dates are closed and
education doesn't happen
it is misleading what school leaders
need is the flexibility to make good
education decisions about those children
that they teach at home those that can
be best taught at home
and those children that need to be in
front of a teacher face to face
uh to make sure that we can really
deliver education it's not just about
gates open and gates closed and this
fixation with the gates are open or
closed isn't helping us
with that education effort and the worry
about primary schools too
um you know the big debate has been
about the announcement over secondary
schools we've got about 15
of primary schools closed right now now
with this new variant we don't know what
direction that's taken and how
infectious
younger children are to to adults in the
community and to each other
and until we understand that we need to
take care with primary why should we
wait until we're another tipping point
with another
another area of the population before we
make good decisions
so we want children in school children
need to be in school but let's organize
an orderly
and orderly and safe return to school
rather than making a mess of it at every
turn
and on remote learning ahead of the
first national lockdown there was
a promise that those children who needed
access to the internet who needed
um laptops they would be delivered
um a lot of questions a lot of criticism
and that that
didn't materialize um are you confident
that
those children who will have to remote
learn will have access to
things like wi-fi and um and a laptop in
order to be able to study effectively
well not all of the kit has been
delivered yet and i noticed in the
secretary of state statement yesterday
the promise to deliver even more of the
million devices that were promised still
fell
short of that million promise so there
are more out there
but the members i represent tell me that
they're not arriving on time
and we have to also get away from just
talking about um
learning at home being through computers
not every child learns well through that
medium and what we've got to do is allow
school leaders and teachers the freedom
to build learning packages that really
deliver
for the children that they're teaching
so let's get the kids out there but
let's not be fixated just about kit
let's have a proper conversation
about what learning at home can look
like it will never replace face-to-face
teaching and we do need to get that
orderly return organized
but in the meantime while we while we
organize that orderly return
let's do the very best that we can get
the kit out there the government needs
to deliver it but let's not be fixated
on that
as the only delivery channel especially
younger children